ashley is going to start us off this
hour in Tennessee hi Ashley how are you
hi good thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up well my husband and
I are making a decision or needing some
help to make a decision quick background
we moved to Franklin last year's have
haven't lived here in about 13 years he
was in the military and we moved away
just move back we purchased a home we
thought we could afford and are now
basically struggling looking at a
furlough he applies for Delta Airlines
and I have taken a pay cut when we moved
here to work remotely from home so I'm
making about 30,000 a year he's making
about 120 a year right now they have him
on reduced pay just trying to figure out
excuse me trying to figure out where I
guess where the chips will fall in the
next ten months so we have acquired over
the past couple years about $70,000
worth of debt the home that we purchased
turns out is a lot more work it's about
six acres and we have we do have some
animals we've got four horses and two
dogs so it has required a lot more work
and a lot more money than we expected
even though we did budget for certain
things and we are facing a decision
about potentially moving to California
away from our family which we just moved
back to you we have a daughter who's 15
months old but out in California he
would have a back-up plan I have
returned to my old salary of about
$80,000 and he would have an opportunity
to make what he's making at Delta and
then son so about 160 and our living
expenses would actually decrease out
there as well with no one else yeah no
they don't live in California decrease
over the farm that you're live on that
you gotta sell but they don't decrease
over Franklin Tennessee well so the
setups were out there would be I would
live on the property of
former I worked or I worked out there in
the resource industry and the the
property that we would be living on that
would only have a rent of about a
thousand dollars a month and then our
horses would board there at my work so
those are our two major costs and so
those would decrease allowing some a lot
more wiggle room in our budget out there
so actually actually have you all
actually sat down and written down the
budget as far as I compare both to each
other and how much is it save oh it's
anything else about six thousand dollars
a month okay I think the the problem is
you presented two options both suck yeah
okay staying where you are is ridiculous
in the situation you're in you
overbought you got you took on more than
you can handle on your plate you're
emotionally drained by this property and
financially drained by this property and
that was all exposed by his furlough it
was already occurring but it was exposed
and heightened highlighted by the
furlough but you wanted to be near your
family and you left California yeah okay
so I I think there's a third option or a
fourth option or a fifth option or sixth
option okay I mean just going back to
where you came from that didn't work so
you left it is a bad option staying
where you are in a situation is a bad
option so okay here's what I heard and
you can take this for whatever you want
to use it for okay look I think you've
got a property that you overbought by
double and I think it absolutely was an
asinine purchase and it has something to
do with horses and your love for them
and I think if I'm in your shoes I'm
going to decide if I want my 15 year old
to be near their grandparents and the
quality of life and the situation of the
community that you're in and move into a
property that's one-third of what you
paid this in your immediate area and you
and do that because you bought some
stinking expensive real estate did I
miss something yes no that's your
hundred percent correct okay now here's
the hard one
no not gonna have room for any little
animals hard in it but this is the place
where you choose where you're going to
raise your 15 month-old whether or
whether you have horses because these
horses are killing you mathematically
because you're making all of your plans
around where horses live in this whole
discussion in both cases you made a bad
purchase year and you're talking about
making a bad decision to go back to
California because in both cases there
was a place for a horse and that sounds
really harsh because you're a horse
person and I understand that but I'm
just telling you I think when you get to
the end of your life you're going to be
a lot more concerned with where you
raised your kid then whether or not you
add horses and in this stage of your
life for sure so if I were in your shoes
I would consider a possible third option
among others and you can look at others
if you don't like mine I'm fine you're
an adult you get to do what you want to
do but it would be sell that property in
all those animals and stay in the area
that is half the cost and let's get
Delta Airlines back up and flying which
it will it's just a matter of when and
it's not two years it's it's not two
months probably but it's not two years
let's get them back up and flying and
let's remember why you came here and you
just though you did a good thing the
wrong way when you came to Franklin and
you overbought and you took on too much
responsibility and then you had a baby
so that's what I heard you saying now
you can do what you want to do and
you'll be mad at me I'm not trying to
make you mad at me I'm trying to love
you well and just tell you the truth so
but you got to decide because I'm it's
not my horses if you told me I had to
sell my dog I'd have to think about it a
lot because I love my dog
but um but not gonna choose my dog over
my 15 month old either that's true Dave
so um and he better not growl at one of
my grandkids again if he wants to live
so mean little Shih Tzu but I looked at
my desk I can take you out boy you know
I can take so um but yeah that's you
know that it's a dog yeah I love my dog
but there's not my grandkids don't mess
with my grandkids and so you just got to
lay out okay what are our family's
priorities and where do we want to live
where do we want to make our life in
proximity to family with a 15 month old
and where do we want to make our life
and then later on as you rebuild wealth
maybe you add some of these things back
maybe you've got a seven-year-old and
you've become millionaires six years
from now and you can afford to move up
in property or buy a piece of property
that gives you room to have horses again
at that point but the care and feeding
of very large four-legged animals is
expensive so is they are expensive hobby
and you know at best or they're
expensive so and again I know you love
them and I know I'm stepping all over
your toes but just want good things for
you honey and I think of a different
option this is the Dave Ramsey show